[Music]
okay okay I gotta tell jokes okay
how are you guys doing this is so
exciting my name is Megan Yuka fright
tell that's my name it's a pretty dumb
name it's not the worst white girl name
it's not Becky but it's top ten you know
like I've definitely had black women I
didn't know be like move Megan and I'm
like you know this I went out last
weekend and I was waiting in line for
the bar and the girl behind me got very
very impatient and she yelled out I
shouldn't have to be standing here I
used to be in pageants well well well
well well well we did not know that you
had a fat mom
that's my meanest joke thank you my mom
is here tonight are you having fun
you're having fun okay
keep sending me money thank you I love
my parents very much I just spent seven
days with them in Indiana yeah well
that's where they live yeah we were like
new vacation spot that's their home my
parents are the cutest nicest most
wonderful people my parents look like
every couple that's ever been in an
erectile disfunction commercial a lot of
sweaters around the neck kayaking trips
tiptoeing up to the Attic to have sex
it's like you own the house to do it in
your bedroom
my baby toys are up there my mom is the
best when I was at home she said thank
you for your service to a mall cop
people here Indiana and they
automatically think sort of racist
hillbillies
that's not my family they're very
open-minded my dad works for a Pakistani
company or as my mom calls it
[Laughter]
I'm 100% Irish a lot of potato famine
survivors here tonight it gets a little
tricky within there though because my
mom is Irish Catholic and my dad is
Irish Protestant very bad in white
people and for those of you that don't
understand what that means
it's kind of like saying my mom was
raised believing in magic and my dad was
raised blowing up magicians
[Applause]
my dad is a drunk obviously like why
would I be here yeah something went
wrong who needs the best like when I was
younger I'd always be like that's so fun
mom so mean why can't dad be in charge
and I'm like oh we would have been dead
okay good call
he's such a good drunk he's successfully
avoided going to rehab for 30 years
based solely on grabbing us with
presents that's all it takes for any of
us to forget like every year on
Christmas they have those car
commercials and someone gets a brand-new
Mercedes or like a big red bow on top of
it I'm always like oh there dad's a
drunk too she'll be like I love your
earrings I'm gonna get my dad like to
thank ya we finally realized was an
issue because he passed out during the
Super Bowl and he like loves football
and was at the Super Bowl so like this
is kind of a $10,000 whoopsie-daisy
so like Dec you're gonna have to go to
rehab like there's just become a really
big issue he's like I just don't
understand how I'm gonna be able to go
to rehab when I'm taking us to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please